[Musique]
bonjour alexis poulain bonsoir plutôt à
l'éditorialiste bonsoir bruno mais
gardanne un chef du service heures de
réanimation à l'hôpital lariboisière et
pierre frey dans les billets mère l air
de dreux première chose alexis poulain
voilà emmanuel macron va donc s'exprimer
ce vendredi soit quelques jours avant le
5 mai est-ce qu'il a enfin compris
l'urgence de ne pas laisser les français
dans l'angoissé et l'incertitude
alors c'est pas une question d'ailleurs
de tonghua soudain certitude aujourd'hui
on est dans l'improvisation permanente
et donc la communication la sur
communication qu'est ce qui se passe
c'est à peu près toujours la même
séquence de communication qui se répète
chaque semaine un conseil de défense
mercredi avec le conseil des ministres
qui est moins important puis une prise
de parole du premier ministre du
ministre de la santé coup dans notre
ministre le jeudi puis alors s'appuiera
la parole du président même si il passe
son temps à prendre la parole de manière
détournée
lundi il était devant une classe de cm2
il disait que peut-être que 19 heures
c'était trop tôt pour le couvre-feu puis
parler au maire et on entendait des ddd
à propos de jean louis emmanuel macron a
dit au maire que peut-être il allait se
passer quelque chose
et un petit signe énorme et là jean
castex qui prend la parole pour dire que
le président va parler aux français et
il va nous parler
vendredi donc c'est ultra
présidentialisation de la gestion de
crise fait que aimerait le maquereau est
l'alpha et l'oméga de toutes les
annonces décidé en conseil de défense
mais qu'il doit incarner finalement
cette gestion improvisée parce que la
stratégie on ne l'a jamais vu depuis
mars 2020 et donc on attend sa parole
comme si c'était le messie qui allait
vous dire quelque chose d'important mais
chaque semaine finalement chasse l'autre
et on oublie tout ce qui a été dit les
objectifs qui avaient été donnés les
horizons fixer les dates les chiffres
également rappelez-vous en fonction du
taux d'expérience on ferme les écoles là
c'est pire
on rouvre les écoles mais c'est pas
grave apparemment la situation est
empreint de saint andré selon jean
castex à 6000 patients dans les services
de réanimation
je ne sais pas comment font les
soignants aujourd'hui je pense qu'ils
sont
au bord du burn out très fatigués ils
font tout ce qu'ils peuvent pour tenir
mais les politiques peut continuer sur
ce qu'ils savent faire de mieux c'est à
dire communiqué ça serait oublier
justement on a eu un cancer il s'est
tourné une nouvelle fois vers les élus
locaux cette semaine pour voir avec eux
ce fameux plan de déconfinement
progressif est aussi un temps d'analysé
est-ce que leur voix elle va vraiment
compter face aux nombreux finalement
conseil de défense sanitaire jugé opaque
par beaucoup on sait qu'il en a fait un
élément clé dans ses prises de décision
si vous voulez nous nous vivons au
quotidien ce que les français vivent son
terrain nous intéresse c'est de faire
remonter le sentiment général auprès du
gouvernement pour que les décisions qui
vont être prises et les annonces qui
vont être réalisés soit cohérente par
rapport à ce qu'attendent les français
savent et de ms a sorti un rapport avec
quelques jours qui parle de fatigue
endémique et c'est très intéressant
comme terme qu on voit bien que les gens
sont usés par une série d'annoncés qui
sont souvent erratique et qui font
perdre la boussole à tout le monde
l'om est s'explique bien dans ce rapport
que pour rassurer les français en
l'occurrence ici c'est qu'il faut bien
avoir de la clarté de la transparence
des étapes une durée pour une sortie de
tunnel et c'est ça qu'on dont on a
besoin ici vous savez des commerçants
des artisans des chefs d'entreprise ils
sont réellement dans une détresse
économique certes mais dans une détresse
aussi psychologiques et là vraiment
j'invite le gouvernement à faire très
attention à ce qu'ils vont faire
monsieur poulin raison il ya beaucoup de
communication mais il faut la
transparence et dire les choses
une fois pour toutes clairement oui
est-ce qu'on va ouvrir au mois de mai
les terrasses on pourra reparler
d'ailleurs parce qu'il ya plusieurs
choses à dire là-dessus savez un
restaurateur ou pris à une terrasse il
n'y a pas forcément le faire parce que
est-ce qu'il y en a eu une déjà on ne
sait pas et est ce que la terrasse va
permettre à son business plan et à son
restaurant de tourner si c'est pas sûr
vous ne faut pas dire n'importe quoi
mais faut des choses claires précises et
des étapes dans le temps qui nous donne
la sortie du tunnel mais c'est des
consignes mans en fonction du taux
d'incidence
par région c'est du bon sens écoutez
c'est le sens du projet de loi qui est
sorti aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'en
fait on va sortir de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire certes mais le gouvernement va
regarder des prérogatives très important
sur les restrictions de liberté est ce
que je rappelle ce sont des restrictions
de liberté que nous vivons actuellement
c'est pas facile c'est pas la tradition
française et sur les terrains de
l'intervention du président vendredi
écoutez il ya un match de foot il parle
vendredi ils essayent de cet arc aller
avec tout l'événement c'est assez
intéressant
enfin bref voilà il faut qu'ils parlent
mais attention parce que sa parole est
en train de fusée comme le disait
monsieur poulin il veut annoncer des
choses à nathan de messi puis des fois
y'a rien donc simplement parler clair
par les transparents synthétique et
soutenu que les français puissent
entendre le message parce que quand vous
êtes dans la situation où on est si on a
une chose les choses claires il ya
l'espoir qui se crée avec des choses
certaines et du coup les gens peuvent se
projeter et ça qui est important
on va regarder avec vous bruno mégarde
année les chiffres de l'épidémie en
france selon le premier ministre la
situation sanitaire
oui les chiffres continuent de
s'améliorer régulièrement pourtant on le
voit les indicateurs sont toujours très
haut même si on est passé tout juste
sous la barre des 6000 patients en soins
critiques
est-ce qu'il a raison bruno meyer ban
d'affirmer que ça va mieux avec de tels
indicateurs
alors effectivement la situation
s'améliore dans le sens où l'épidémie
régresse
le nombre de nouvelles contaminations
quotidienne diminue certes à une vitesse
plus lente que ce que l'on a connu en
mars avril 2020 à la suite du
confinement strict une vitesse deux à
trois fois plus lente alors le problème
c'est que cette fois ci nous avons
atteint une saturation très élevés des
services de réanimation et effectivement
aujourd'hui nous sommes sur un plateau
très haut de l'ordre de 6000 admission
en réanimation et il a attendu que ce
nombre
descroix extrêmement lentement donc lui
la situation s'améliore mais nous sommes
sur un plateau très élevé et on espère
effectivement que vers la mine et avec
la réouverture promise
l'épidémie ne repart pas c'est pourquoi
il est très important évidemment de
programmer un déconfinement
territorialisée et très progressif
adapté à la situation épidémiologique
c'est à dire à la fois à l'incidence des
nouvelles de nouvelles contaminations
mais aussi au taux de saturation des
services de réanimation
parce que lors des deux derniers à des
consignes mans les chiffres étaient
beaucoup plus bas oui tout à fait c'est
à dire qu'en fait l'occupation des
services de réanimation par les patients
et la comédie 19 étaient plus bas et la
vitesse de régression des épidémies un
peu un peu plus rapide donc c'est
pourquoi il faut être un peu plus
prudent malgré tout ce qui change par
rapport à la dernière fois c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une vaccination qui
progresse et puis nous sommes à l'entrée
de la saison chaude donc là aussi le
mode de vie va se modifier c'est à dire
on va surtout vivre à l'extérieur les
fenêtres ouvertes
et donc ces conditions évidemment ne
favorise pas la propagation du virus
mais comme vous le savez évidemment nous
avons cette fois ci des variantes qui
sont à la porte du pays et donc il faut
être de toute façon extrêmement prix
viendrait de régliez l'état d'urgence
sanitaire c'est notre annonce de jean
castex prend fin le 2 juin
enfin pas vraiment vous allez nous dire
ce que vous en pensez puisque le
gouvernement annoncer un régime
transitoire jusqu'au 31 octobre
oui c'est une version si vous voulez
allégé qui va perdre et de pouvoir
cibler des territoires qui sont plus ou
moins touchés et de faire un peu un
travail en dentelle sur l'idée c'est pas
idiot et on comprend bien c'est l'esprit
de la loi savait que le conseil d'état
est très précis là-dessus c'est à dire
que quand vous êtes hors état d'urgence
sanitaire
il faut une limitation dans l'espace
d'art géographique et une déviation dans
le temps c'est l'esprit des lois qui va
être déposée
ça répond à peu près aux critères bon on
sort d'état d'urgence version allégée en
gardant quand même
le gouvernement peut garder quand même
des possibilités de décret et autres
pour toujours restreint les libertés
nord
on verra on espère tout ça va être très
pragmatique il faut que les gens aussi
puissent se projeter au mois de juillet
au mois d'août pour partir en vacances
il faut que le tourisme repartent en
france avec ses premiers étaient
hostiles du monde c'est quand même pas
rien 90 millions de gens viennent en
france visiter notre pays donc il faut
qu'on accélère sur la vaccination
j'ai entendu j'ai entendu que des
vaccins se perdre et à écouter donné
l'idée à dreux on laissera très bien il
ya une chambre de ben y'a pas de soucis
voilà est en tout cas il faut absolument
que le mois de juin c'est un mois clé on
puisse vraiment monter en charge en
vaccination ce qui nous permettra
d'avoir des perspectives en juillet en
août
on va parler de la vaccination biens
sont allés que ses poulains le
gouvernement va pouvoir prendre des
mesures restrictives tout de même comme
la fermeture des commerces elle limitait
aussi les déplacements finalement ce
régime transitoire
parce qu'on doit considérer comme une
exception pas c'est tout le problème des
régimes transitoires c'est qu'ils ont
tendance à s'inscrire dans le temps long
et puis finalement à s'inscrire dans la
loi vigipirate ça fait combien d'années
maintenant qu'on est sous ce régime mais
c'est une veille citoyenne les régimes
d'exception aussi là on voit bien que
l'idée c'est de prolonger de pouvoir
agir vite si on voit des clusters se
former en région pouvoir à nouveau fermé
des commerces pour voir à nouveau
empêché la circulation des personnes
puisque c'est comme ça que le virus
circule malheureusement donc on voit
l'idée en parallèle de ça il ya quand
même la volonté d'imposer un pass
sanitaire le pass vert européen
passeport vaccinale si on veut et là les
contours sont très floues c'est à dire
qu'on nous parle d'abord pour voyager ça
on peut le comprendre pour passer d'une
frontière à l'autre même si c'est
difficile à comprendre mais on ne sait
pas s'il va falloir l'avoir avec soi
pour pouvoir aller dans des commerces
c'est le cas en allemagne par exemple où
vous devez faire des tests pour aller
dans certains commerces
est-ce qu'en france il faudra avoir son
qr code sur l'appli stop coville pour
pouvoir aller au restaurant aller au
cinéma et au théâtre
la ministre de la culture roselyne
bachelot est tout à fait contre mais
elle ne pourra pas l'empêcher si c'est
le cas et on voit bien que jean castex
et gênés 1 il ne disait c'est quelque
chose qui attaquent nos libertés
fondamentales d'une certaine façon donc
c'est un outil totalement liberticide
assumée comme telle et peut-être la
porte d'entrée de cette carte de la
citoyenneté un convoi en chine où vous
mauvais concitoyens et ça vous ouvre des
droits ou pas et ce serait la fin de
l'égalité en l'égalité c'est un des
trois piliers de la république liberté
égalité fraternité
si on commence à m ce pass sanitaire en
place quel sera le périmètre est là il
n'y a pas de réponse et c'est ça qui
fait peur dans ce régime transitoire
c'est qu'on voit bien qu'on est en train
de tester
finalement des solutions pour ouvrir ou
fermer la cage des hamsters voir
jusqu'où ils peuvent aller s'ils ont
droit de consommer tel produit essentiel
ou non si la culture est essentielle
ou pas et tout ça alors que les concerts
on l'a vu un le concertiste en espagne a
prouvé qu'il n'y avait pas eu de
contamination suite à ce concert avec
des protocoles bien sûr mais donc il y a
des façons de réouvrir autre que celui
du pass sanitaire donc moi ce qui me
fait peur avec ce régime transitoire
c'est simplement la phase test de ce
pass sanitaire qui va devenir l'alpha et
l'oméga de notre vie citoyenne notre vie
de tous les jours et là on entre dans
une autre société qui est celle de la
techno surveillance du fichage permanent
fichage biologique puisqu'il est
question là de votre santé de votre état
de santé
et on ne sait pas jusqu'où ça peut aller
très dangereuse son débat bioéthique
mais elles sont le plan je veux dire
médical bruno meyer bella ce que ce pass
sanitaires il sait sens mars que c'est
un outil nécessaire et utile oui tout à
fait c'est quelque chose d'important
pourquoi parce que tout d'abord vous
allez pouvoir être avertis et alerter si
vous entrez en contact avec une personne
porteuse du virus donc cela va
encourager le dépistage et l'isolément
c'est la fameuse stratégie de dépister
tracé isolé qui certes va devoir être
installé un taux de encore de
circulation de virus est élevé mais
malgré tout il faut l'optimiser
avec ce système effectivement numérique
par ailleurs effectivement le pass and i
ter sera important pour garantir la
réouverture des lieux sociaux
donc il faut pas le voir comme un va
dire une limite aux libertés mais plutôt
un moyen pour permettre justement de
trouver nos libertés en toute sécurité
enfin bien sûr lorsque l'on va voyager
c'est indispensable
tous les pays vont le mettre en place et
donc quiconque souhaitera partir à
l'étranger devra absolument à voir se
passe à lutter pour éviter d'être en
quarantaine pendant une quinzaine de
jours
à l'arrivée dans le pays de destination
malheureusement nous sommes dans une
situation de pandémie il y à des risques
vitaux pour chacun d'entre nous si les
contaminés non vaccinés il faut donc
prendre des précautions et c'est ce
moyen qui va nous permettre de freiner
la circulation du virus et on l'espère
évidemment à la rentrée avec une
vaccination plus importante de la
population retrouver une vie quasi
normale en septembre octobre
si malheureusement la vaccination est
trop lente si un certain pourcentage des
personnes à risque n'est pas vacciné il
faut attendre octobre à 1 re démarrage
de l'épidémie comme on l'a connu en 2020
et donc malheureusement des mesures de
restriction il faut donc tout faire pour
favoriser ce nouveau mode de vie qui on
l'espère ne sera pas inscrit dans la
durée je cas frédéric didier justement
c'est un vous êtes favorable à ce pas
sanitaire est ce que c'est indispensable
dit comme alexis poulenc c'est un outil
phare attention ici peut être
liberticide et bien il sera quand même
soumis aux parlementaires
oui il y aura un débat parlementaire et
c'est très bien ça peut en ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est qu'il ya des
interactions aussi en europe
un passeport vaccinale si vous voyagez
partir les pays frontaliers et autres
pays demanderont vous soyez vacciner que
vous aviez la coiffe de sa première
chose après moi j'suis assez pragmatique
c'est à dire que le passeport vaccinale
ça permet de faire redémarrer l'économie
redémarre et des commerces qu'on puisse
retrouver un semblant de vie normale
voilà je suis pour mais quelles sont les
conditions qui vont être posées par le
parlement est-ce qu'on va garantir les
libertés individuelles est ce que les
datas les données qui seront collectés
seront parfaitement sécurisé il ya des
questions qui se posent donc il faut
aussi que l'état soit en mesure de
rassurer les français sur
la mise en place et de service après
vente de ce passeport maximale sur le
plan de la vaccination on y vient à
l'excès poulin et à peut-être une
incohérence
parce que jean castex a affirmé que
l'élargissement des publics était
prématuré alors qu on s'en souvient le
ministre de la santé ollier vers en a
et d'affirmer que la population seraient
vaccinés d'ici la fin de l'été les
délais là ça semble quand même compromis
c'est parce que dijon cassettes avec soi
même dit que les chiffres de 20 millions
à mi mai et 30 millions 1 mi juin sont
tout à fait probable première dose à une
vaccination à deux piqûres
la question qui se pose c'est le gâchis
on peut pas continuer comme ça à avoir
des places de vaccination qui sont vides
alors que des personnes qui souhaitent
se faire vacciner ne peuvent pas le
faire par manque alors soit par manque
de logistique d'acheminement des doses
soit par manque de doses mais il faut
dire ce qui est alors il ya le problème
d'astrazeneca et avec une certaine
défiance des populations ont vu les
couacs nombreux qui a pu avoir
on a essayé de rassurer en disant que
vous savez bon alors le bénéfice risque
en fonction de votre âge est quand même
largement du côté du bénéfice mais on
voit que les français rechignent quand
même et préfère certains vaccins à
d'autres mais derrière il ya une logique
de dire si vous souhaitez de vacciner
vous devez pouvoir le faire dès
maintenant
le risque c'est effectivement de voir
qu'il n'y ait pas assez de doses pour
les populations à risques prioritaires
parce que rétro de demandes de la part
de gens qui souhaitent se faire vacciner
qui ne font pas partie des populations à
risque mais si on voit que ça ne
fonctionne pas dans les métiers
prioritaires ou dans les cases
prioritaire il va falloir trouver une
autre note un autre mode de
fonctionnement
certains ont essayé du côté du privé
s'est vite ma dose de du commis de
traqueur par exemple qui permettront d
vous rapidement
olivier ferrand qui dit aller vérifier
auprès des centres de vaccination s'il
reste des doses s'il ya une place vous
pouvez à ce moment-là y aller parce
qu'on ne peut pas continuer comme ça
quotidiennement avoir des doses qui ne
trouve pas preneur alors qu'elles sont
programmés dans la campagne de
vaccination à bruno mégarde annoncera
tout se vacciner d'ici la fin de l'été
pensez à ce rythme on l'espère on
l'espère on voit bien qu'il y à 2
remettre très important le premier c'est
la disponibilité des doses de vaccin je
crois que ce point sera rapidement
résolu et on va dire dans les semaines
qui viennent il y aura suffisamment de
vaccins disponibles pour ceux qui
souhaiteront et vaccinés et puis
évidemment il la volonté de chacun
d'entre nous d'être vaccinés on voit
bien que à un moment malheureusement on
va atteindre les limites des personnes
volontaires il faudra à nouveau acte et
de pédagogie pour convaincre la totalité
des personnes car on sait qu
effectivement s'il restait dans une
proportion significative de personnes à
risque non vaccinés à la fin de l'été en
septembre octobre
on risque à nouveau d'avoir une nouveau
démarrage de l'épidémie avec à nouveau
un an quand une saturation des hôpitaux
et des lits de réanimation et donc
malheureusement la mise en place de
fêtes de mesures de restriction c'est ce
que tout le monde veut éviter
il faut savoir que la vaccination de
c'est d'abord une protection
individuelle mais c'est aussi contribué
pour protéger les autres et bien sûr
permettre un retour rapide à la vie
normale
pour conclure pierre frédéric veiller
sur les délais de réouverture des
terrasses que c'est un rendez vous
important à l'animé des commerces dont
essentiel aussi il faut rouvrir avant le
13 mai l'ascension il ya des jours
fériés au mois de mai et c'est vrai que
ça peut être intéressant pour les
commerces qui ont perdu beaucoup de
chiffres d'affaires tout à fait je vais
vous répondre sur des questions et je
vais vous donner en guise de conclusion
un chiffre qui est intéressant alors oui
il faut faire confiance à nos
commerçants parce que ce sont des gens
responsables
les consommateurs viennent respecte et
gestes-barrières il n'y a pas trop de
problématiques sur les commerces il faut
leur faire confiance
juste un dernier chiffre en guise de
conclusion à dreux nous avons vacciné à
ce jour en primo vacciner 12 mille cinq
cents personnes
et ceci depuis début janvier
si j'avais les doses nécessaires au
maximum douze mille personnes c'est ce
que je pourrais faire en une semaine sur
une semaine de sept jours
c'est juste pour vous donner l'effort
que nous faisons financièrement nos
collectivités
le nombre de gens vaccinés en plus tôt
moi est à relativiser avec un nombre de
doses maximales qu'on pourrait avoir
qu'on pourrait faire en une semaine
merci beaucoup pierre fred et régulier
je rappelle que cette mère a l'air de
dreux merci à vous également bruno
m'égare ban chef du service réanimation
à l'hôpital lariboisière et alexis
poulain éditorialistes